when you believe a thing believe it all
the way implicitly and unquestionably
what Disney
I was unhappy I started my business
because I wanted to help entrepreneurs I
struggled so much to get my first
business off the ground and almost gave
up one of the worst days of my life was
when I told my business partner I quit I
was tired of putting in all this time
and effort and money and not seeing
results I was tired of working for less
than minimum wage I was tired of losing
respect for myself and feeling like a
total failure I managed to pull through
beat the odds and be one of the success
stories and I wanted to share my
experience and advice with others
because I almost didn't make it I wanted
to make their path a little easier than
what I had to go through but I was
unhappy I was unhappy because I started
doing all sorts of different projects a
website YouTube videos radio shows media
interviews and so on but I wasn't
getting people talking about my business
enough it seemed to scattered people
couldn't wrap their heads around what I
did because it was all over the place I
needed clarity I thought it was a
marketing problem so I met with a friend
Jason to try to come up with a tagline
for my business over the years it had
gone from helping you build the company
of your dreams to motivational
strategies for entrepreneurs to over 20
million entrepreneurs helped and
Counting weaksauce what we came up with
was hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
this felt better but still wasn't quite
right something was missing and I
couldn't put my finger on it then Steve
Jobs changed my life one day stumbled
upon what would become one of my
favorite youtube videos of all time it
was Steve Jobs talking about marketing
it hit on exactly what I was missing the
core selling that made Apple so
successful it had a dramatic impact on
my business and my life here's part of
what Steve said
to me marketing's about values this is a
very complicated world it's a very noisy
world and we're not going to get a
chance to get people to remember much
about us no company is and so we have to
be really clear on what we want them to
know about us now appala fortunately is
one of the half-a-dozen best brands in
the whole world right up there with Nike
Disney Coke Sony it is one of the greats
of the greats not just in this country
but all around the globe and but but but
even a great brand needs investment and
caring if it's going to retain its
relevance and vitality and the Apple
brand has clearly suffered from neglect
in this area in the last few years and
we need to bring it back the way to do
that is not to talk about speeds and
fees it's not to talk about nips and
negatives it's not to talk about why
you're better than windows the dairy
industry tried for 20 years to convince
you that milk was good for you it's a
lie but they try it anyway and the sales
were going like this and then they tried
got milk and the sales are going like
this got me off the thing to talk about
apartment that focuses on the absence of
the product but
but but the best example of all and and
one of the greatest jobs of of marketing
in though if the universe has ever seen
as Nike remember Nike sells a commodity
they sell shoes and yet when you think
of Nike you feel something different
than a shoe company in their ads as you
know they don't ever talk about the
products they don't ever tell you about
their air soils and why they're better
than Reebok their souls
what is Nike doing they're advertising
they they honor great athletes and they
honor great athletics that's who they
are that's what they are about Apple
spend a fortune on advertising you'd
never know it you've never known so when
I got here we Apple just fired the
agency we're doing a competition with 23
agencies that you know four years from
now we'll pick one and we blew that up
and we we hired Shaddai the ad agency
that I was fortunate enough to work with
years ago we created some award-winning
work including the commercial brothers
the best dad ever made 1984 by
advertising professionals and you
started working about eight weeks ago
and what was the question they asked was
our customers want to know who is Apple
and what is it that we stand for where
do we fit in this world and what we're
about isn't making boxes for people to
get their job done
although we do that well we do that
better than almost anybody in some cases
but apples about something more than
that Apple at the core its core value is
that we believe that people if fashion
can change the world for the better
that's what we believe and we've had the
opportunity to work with people like
that we've had an opportunity work with
people like me with software developers
with customers who have done it in some
big and some small ways and we believe
that in this world people can change it
for the better and that those people
that are crazy enough to think they can
change the world are the one could
actually do if you act on what Steve
Jobs said you'll spark a movement this
speech was given just after Steve Jobs
returned to Apple in his absence Apple
had struggled it was a few months away
from bankruptcy had only four percent
market share and was losing over a
billion dollars a year asking Jobs to
come back was a desperation move Apple
had just been through three different
CEOs and nobody could make it work
Jobs agreed and took his company from
life support to being the most valuable
company in the world it might be the
single greatest turnaround story of all
time it's time for your business to
start taking off - in this speech Jobs
outlines the basics of course selling
the way to do that is not to talk about
speeds and feeds it's not to talk about
bits and megahertz that's feature
selling it's not to talk about why we're
better than Windows and what we're about
isn't making boxes or people to get
their jobs done although we do that well
that's benefit self marketing is about
values we have to be really clear on
what we want them to know about us Apple
at the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion can
change the world for the better that's
what we believe and we believe that in
this world people can change it for the
better and that those people who are
crazy enough to think that they can
change the world are the ones that
actually do
that's core selling mind-blown I finally
had some clarity it was time to get to
work if you want to model Steve Jobs as
amazing results you need to get just as
clear about who you are and what you
stand for
once you have clarity everything else
falls into place I was frustrated that
my business didn't have enough momentum
and I didn't have the clarity I needed
to move forward so I made a list to try
to find my core value I started with my
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
tagline I wrote down ideas for how to
convey the emotion behind my work
something that really got my blood
pumping I purposely tried not to think
too much and instead just started
writing whatever entered my mind here's
what I came up with hungry hunters
deserve help what I do what I believe
but not inspirational entrepreneurs
changed the world
entrepreneurs are heroes celebrate
entrepreneurs rallying cry gets your
heart pumping it's on you take your shot
believe follow your passion overcome
persevere keep going
step up don't settle start I didn't love
anything on the list yet nothing felt
quite right yet so I decided to sleep on
it if you're struggling to make a
decision sleep on it and see how you
feel in the morning I felt inspired by
Steve Jobs and was ready to act but was
frustrated that I couldn't get my
clarity
I wanted it badly but it wasn't coming
so I slept on it I came back to the same
list the next day and one word jumped
out believe it was right there in the
middle of my list I thought about what
believe meant to me I came up with this
believe in what you're doing
passion believe that you can do it
confidence believe that it will work
conviction finally because I felt
believe on its own was too simple our
student looking for ways to add to it
believe you can believe in the possible
believe more believe it all believe in
belief believe in believe the more I
looked at the list the more I realized
that I just like believe so I decided I
was going to do this crazy thing
and rebrand my entire business around
believe it felt right and my life was
about to change
the one thing that hit me pretty quickly
was that this was more than just a
slogan this was a value this was a
personal mission statement this was a
way of life believe became hashtag
believe it started my movement I look
back at the people I had hired on my
team and the ones who were still with me
were the ones who also had believed as a
core value I reflected on my personal
life and realized that I've always been
about believing but I never realized it
I loved reading books about the little
guy who overcame the odds to be
successful my favorite book is
Seabiscuit which is a story of an
undersized racehorse whose victories
lifted a nation in the middle of the
Great Depression
my favorite entrepreneur is AP Giannini
the founder of Bank of America who made
loans of as little as $25 the people
whose only collateral was the calluses
on their hands he would lend money based
on a man's face and a signature my
friends are about believe the songs I
like are about believe everything that
makes me come alive somehow relates to
believe believe isn't a marketing slogan
for me it's Who I am you need to find
who you are then you can start making
some important decisions
[Music]